Thanksgiving wasn't always like it is
today,
the domestic family meal football,
the parade leftovers,
black Friday like Christmas.
It used to be a holiday of festivals,
outdoor revelry,
and drinking too much like today's
Halloween.
In fact,
children would dress up in costumes and
go begging for money or treats.
If you were growing up in 19th century,
New York City,
you might see a group of crossdressers
called the fantastical marching the city
streets ridiculing authority figures.
It wasn't until the mid 18 hundreds that
Sarah Josepha Hale,
the godmother of Thanksgiving as we know
it,
started writing her famous editorials in
goatees magazine,
recontextualizing the holiday as a
domestic occasion,
one in which distance sons and daughters
returned home for a family feast.
She urged governors and presidents to
adopt the last Thursday in November as a
national holiday,
and her letters shake with notes of
urgency and the spare is the country
slid to civil war.
Thanksgiving,
she hoped might hold together under the
banner of brotherhood and gratitude of
Fragile Union.
It didn't work,
of course,
but in 18,
63,
president Lincoln did make Thanksgiving,
a federal holiday.
The point of pride for Union states then
for the rest of the country as it
rebuilt after the war,
Hail Lincoln and others of that period
effectively rewrote Thanksgiving as
something that happens in doors with
families,
a joyful reuniting but no longer have
rawkus.
The tectonic changes of the industrial
and commercial revolutions were pulling
families apart.
They felt threatening to weaken the ties
and values that grounded the nation over
the next decades into the 20th century.
Thanksgiving lost its tolerance for
begging children and drunk and marchers
and picked up new traditions like annual
football games and the macy's Day parade
teachers taught the story of
Thanksgiving to their students,
many of whom urge their immigrant
parents to celebrate the national
ritual,
a way of stirring patriotism,
and as with all forms of assimilation,
foreign cultures are both absorbed into
and erased by the dominant culture.
The thanksgiving Turkey and its many
side dishes are a great metaphor for
these twin tendencies and many brought
dishes from their own cultures into the
feast to remember their diverse pasts.
As long as the Turkey rained.
Overall,
this is all to say that traditions like
Thanksgiving aren't natural by any
means.
They're invented and at the time of
their invention they call to a past
that's not really there and imagined
past a constructed authenticity that
serves the purposes of the president.
Indeed,
even the awareness of such traditions is
a relatively modern phenomenon,
anchoring points for a culture in
constant and progressively more rapid
change.
There's a lot in the DNA of Thanksgiving
worth holding onto,
but there's a lot of which we'd be
better off without a rosy and false
account of our early settlers,
friendship with the native Americans and
ideology of female domesticity and
anachronistic remnant of the separate
spheres.
Way of thinking that said,
a woman's rightful place was at home in
front of the stove.
The assimilation of other cultures,
races,
and classes into a largely white and
largely Protestant system of thinking.
For me,
the core of Thanksgiving is family.
The family I was born into,
the family I chose,
the community I live in and the nation
that gives me the freedom to think
through and if I want criticize it's
values.
These days in the wake of terror around
the world,
what our worst reactionary tendencies
are flared by those far too willing to
stoke fear
at anchor.
It's worth remembering,
I think just how many different families
we all belong to.
We may be celebrating in separate homes,
but in reality,
each family in America blends into the
next.
If the history of Thanksgiving shows us
anything,
it's that holidays like these are open
to revision as Americans.
Thanksgiving is ours to reframe just as
the country is.
That's an important responsibility for
all of us.
Have responsibility for which I give.
Thanks.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching and happy
Thanksgiving to everybody out there.
I hope you're with your families or with
people that you love going home to my
family and I can't wait to see all of
them.
If you want to support the nerd writer,
if you think that the nerdwriter is
something that you're not seeing
anywhere else on youtube or the
Internet,
you can go right here and pledged to my
patrion page as little as a dollar per
video.
Everything helps.
You guys have been amazing,
so thank you for that.
This money goes toward improving the
channel and making better and better and
better videos and I hope you guys are
seeing a return on what you're giving to
me because,
uh,
it's very,
very generous and I don't take it
lightly.
So thank you guys again,
happy Thanksgiving and I'll see you next
Wednesday.